I love the intensity than GI Jane that
you went and trained with the Navy SEALs
like they say that training most people
crumble it was hardcore I mean we
obviously ours was modified but we had
all real seals down there some hardcore
but with me and 40 guys and I'm telling
you I went down to start the training
and I had stuff hanging in the closet
what is that training exactly well I
mean the first day they had boots and
the whole thing for me and they made us
do the mile run off the bat 5:00 in the
morning I had taken some vitamins on an
empty stomach stupid haul ass mile run
straight out me 40 guys and I like cross
the finish line literally take a right
turn puke my guts out like go get back
in there like okay so by midday we take
a break they're gonna put us in water so
you're doing everything these guys yeah
the other actors extras we're all there
to kind of you know bond and learn the
experience I take my shoes off and I
have these massive blisters and Harry
Humphries our consultant he said you
know you don't really have to do all
this and I thought if I don't right now
I'll never get it back I'll never get it
back of you know the respect I'm playing
an officer like I was like had you know
just give me some tape and I taped up my
you know blisters and off we went
I mean and they never called me by my
real name always by the character name
and I'm telling you they set me up I'm
convinced to be late the first day the
second day so they could ream you and
they and I everyone was information and
I'm like I'm gonna squeak in back in the
back and all of a sudden I hear Jordan
front and center and I'm like I like go
up to the front and I'm like standing
there and he says drop your [ __ ] ass
down right now and I'm like oh wow KK
dragged him push-ups oh he said drop me
down into a lean and rest which is like
a push-up position and he was screaming
who the [ __ ] do you think you are you
think we're gonna let some split tail
come in here and drop your [ __ ] ass
down I was like okay and then I'd like
go in and then he screams at everybody
else and me well neither you don't leave
a man behind you drop your asses down so
then now I'm responsible for everybody
else being in trouble oh my god yeah
that was it but the instructor was
impressed with you yeah you had trouble
with pull-ups
yeah but the instructor would say this
woman's had three kids you [ __ ]
better do it because you were really you
were nailing it